what do the planets closest to us look
like are there extraterrestrial
life-forms these two questions have been
preying on the brightest minds of the
world for a long time for centuries
people have come up with suppositions
and theories until in the 20th century
the scientific and technological
progress enabled scientists to put into
practice one of the most tremendous
projects in space exploration on the 5th
of September 1977 the Voyager 1 probe
was launched sixteen days previously on
the 20th of August 1977 it's twin
Voyager 2 was launched that was the
beginning of a groundbreaking journey
into the unexplored depths of the
universe that has been going on for the
past 42 years
[Music]
the first in the space during this long
time span the voyages have taken
detailed photographs of Jupiter Saturn
as well as their satellites Uranus was
closely studied and it's 11 moons were
discovered thanks to the wider mission
it's the pictures taken by Voyager 2
that allowed scientists to be able to
see one of the most controversial bodies
in the solar system
Myranda Uranus is satellite the subject
of big space travel was first broached
in 1966 Gary flandro still a student
published a scientific paper where he
predicted the orbits of Jupiter Saturn
Uranus and Neptune getting closer
together by the late 1970s the
predictions proved to be accurate on the
10th of March 1982 a fool planetary
parade took place the eight planets of
the solar system and Pluto were in the
same side of the Sun at the angle of 95
degrees
the rendezvous of the giant planets
provided opportunities for using
gravitational maneuvering to fly the two
apparatuses of the trajectories Jupiter
Saturn Pluto and Jupiter Uranus Neptune
10,000 possible trajectories were
considered when the program was being
worked out before the two of them were
finally agreed upon
apart from exploring further most
objects of the solar system
the voyagers have taken a great number
of photos of our own planet including
one of the most well known ones from a
record distance of almost 6 billion
kilometres
the idea of the picture as well as its
name the pale blue dot belongs to a
prominent astrophysicist of the 20th
century and an outstanding popular rise
of science Carl Sagan the scientists
didn't rule out the possibility of the
voyagers encountering extraterrestrial
beings that is why both spacecraft
carried a gold-plated audio-visual disk
with greetings and 55 different
languages significant scientific data
the views of the earth and its position
in relation to its 14 pulses music held
a special place and the message to
intelligent aliens the collection of
music includes classical works by Bach
Mozart Beethoven jazz pieces by Louis
Armstrong and Chuck Berry as well as
folk music from around the world the
record also contains an instruction on
how to access the data on its back
however let us not dwell on the past but
look at the future of the Voyager
project where are the spacecraft now and
what awaits these solitary space
Wanderers
the voyagers chief mission exploration
of further most planets and the solar
system was completed long ago now the
main objective of both probes is
studying transit of areas between the
Sun and interstellar plasma the voyagers
travel at 17 point oh seven kilometers
per second and 15 point 64 kilometers
per second respectively
at the moment this video is posted the
distance between the Earth and Voyager 1
is approximately 21 point 7 billion
kilometers while Voyager 2 is 17 point
nine billion kilometers away from us the
spacecraft's missions differ by their
trajectory a Voyager 1 flew only by
Jupiter and Saturn while Voyager 2 went
further and flew by Uranus and Neptune
as well that is the reason why Voyager 2
is never going to catch up with its twin
brother in 2012
Voyager 1 left the heliosphere
boundaries to cross into interstellar
space it follows a hyperbolic trajectory
so Voyager 1 is not going to return to
the solar system due to the
gravitational force of the latter its
twin overcame the heliopause only
November 2018 leaving the heliosphere
does not actually mean leaving the solar
system to do this one has to go as far
as the Oort cloud a hypothetical region
of the solar system and a place of birth
of ice comets only there will the
gravity force of our star become
negligibly feeble the voyagers are
powered by plutonium-238 radioisotope
thermoelectric generators
after 42 years the power of the probes
went down to 55 percent and is now 249
watt as opposed to 470 watt at the time
of launch this does not allow full
application of the probes scientific
equipment only 5 out of 10 devices are
operating now the cosmic-ray system the
low energy charged particle instrument
the magnetometer the plasma wave
subsystem and the plasma instrument now
the Voyager mission members are
struggling to maintain the equipment's
operation according to preliminary
estimates the minimal energy generation
required for scientific studies will be
sustained until 2025 this time is hoped
to be sufficient to explore interstellar
space in particular the structure of the
heliopause in the future
the data may be used in planning
missions to the stellar system closest
to us Alpha Centauri by about 2030 the
probes will switch into a radio beacon
mode and will transmit to the last
signal to the earth in 2036
thus the life expectancy of the voyagers
will reach about 59 years one must admit
it is quite a period for a space strip
in about 300 years Voyager 2 is going to
reach the inner edge of the Oort cloud
and will completely leave it only in 30
thousand years according to the data
provided by the Hubble telescope it will
take Voyager to approximately 2,000
years to cross the gas cloud in which
the solar system floats it will take the
probe about 90 thousand years to get
into other interstellar clouds the
remains of the voyagers are presumed to
reach stars as well
in about 40,000 years Voyager 1 is
supposed to pass Glee sir 445 a star and
camelopardalis within a 1.6 light years
distance meanwhile its twin will
approach ross 2 4 8 a star in Andromeda
at one point seven light years distance
in 296 thousand years
Voyager 2 will fly by serious at a 4.3
light years distance life-sustaining
planets are unlikely to exist in the
vicinity of either Ross 2 4 8 or glee
sir 4 4 5
both of them are red dwarves each of
them hardly half the mass of the Sun
Ross 2 4 8 is notable for being a flare
star that is one that spontaneously
flares up at about the time Voyager 2
approaches Ross two four eight closest
the closest star to the Sun will for a
short time the Ross two four eight and
not Proxima Centauri the voyagers are to
remain eternal Wanderers in the universe
they won't be able to leave the Milky
Way and a destined to wander around our
galaxy they have lived through scores of
failures on their journey but in spite
of that they continue to operate
transmitting important scientific data
to the earth with the initially planned
five year lifespan
they're pushing their fourth decade of
service as far as I'm concerned the
Voyager project is the most successful
idea in the history of space exploration
the data received during the mission
have changed man's perception of the
solar system it is hard to tell whether
an extraterrestrial race will ever read
the message on the golden plated disks
on the voyages since the solar system is
15 times faster than the voyages it's
circling around the galaxy center it is
possible that our planet will
sure the remains of the probes in some
hundreds of millions of years maybe the
message aimed at aliens will eventually
be a greeting from a distant fast to the
human race of the future please leave
your comments about what other
impressive space exploration programs
you would like to find out more about
like the video if you enjoyed it and
don't forget to subscribe keep in touch
[Music]